longer de cité où chacun a mis son coup
de patte à sa case la rue léonus bénard
annonce la sortie de la ville de
saint-louis peu d'animation peu de
commerces
à cette heure la rue est en sommeil la
mémoire de léonus bénard l'est-elle
aussi ne fait pas gaou comme un eunuque
beynat là-bas on a une relation cops
comment est un prêtre non mais chez le
singe et bien sûr mais n'a été connue
partout dans ces individus au mieux
celui en bon les personnes que l'abri
pour le nom sur mon bain et la fiat est
resté
c'est en hommage à son sénateur maire
que saint louis a nommé cette vue
enfants de la rivière saint louis né en
1882 léonus bénard est d'abord un
industriel qui reprend lusine paternelle
de pierrefonds pour ce faire de cet
enfant le sucre est une bonne affaire
en 1925 la société léonus bénard et
compagnies contrôlent les trois usines
du sud
pierrefonds le goal et les casernes un
envol qui l'incitent dès 1919 à se
lancer dans la politique
là aussi la chance lui sourit à 47 ans
léonus est à la fois maire de
saint-louis président du conseil général
et sénateur
finalement à force de cumuler mandats et
responsabilités léonus bénard fini par
lâcher la mairie de saint louis ainsi
que la présidence du conseil général
promoteur de la route de cilaos vice
président de la chambre d'agriculture
président du syndicat des fabricants de
sucre bâtisseurs des premières cités
ouvrières initiateurs de l'apeca ce
membre de la gauche démocratique
continuera de dominer la vie politique
et économique local jusqu'à la fin des
années 1930 après la deuxième guerre
mondiale il s'installe
et ne viendra plus à la réunion que pour
de courts séjours en 1952
un an après avoir reçu la légion
d'honneur il s'éteint à l'âge de 70 ans
il est inhumé au cimetière de sa ville
natale